في دوامه من الفراغات يدور لبنان الذي دخل
شهره الرابع بدون رئيس للجمهوريه
الكرسي الرئاسي الذي شكل السبب الابرز خلف
خلاف حزب الله والتيار الوطني الحر حال
ايضا دون تامين نصاب جلسه تشريعيه نيابيه
لتفادي فراغ في منصب المدير العام للامن
العام
اللواء عباس ابراهيم يحال على التقاعد في
الثاني من مارس وفي حال عدم التمديد
الابراهيم يحال المنصب الى العميد رمز
الرامي المحسوب على التيار الوطني الحر مش
الخلاف على اسم اللواء عباس ابراهيم
الخلاف هو على مبدا التشريع بغياب رئيس
الجمهوريه او عقد جلسه لمجلس الوزراء
بغياب رئيس الجمهوريه وحتى التمديد لانه
الحزب ما جرى جبران باسيل بالتمديد لبعض
المدراء العامين مثل رورفالي ابن فهلا
جبران مثل بيقولوا باللبناني عم بيرد عم
بيرد العمليه هي ذاتها للحزب بس بنهايه
المطاف يبدو انه في الا ما يكون في مخارج
يعتمدوا عليها التمديد
الوطن اللبناني ونشيده الامن العام خلف
الكواليس اتصالات واجتماعات لايجاد حلول
لتفادي الشهور في اكثر من موقع امني بينها
منصب قائد الجيش الذي اعلن عن عدم رغبته
في التمديد ومنصب المدير العام لقوى الامن
الداخلي اللواء عماد عثمان الذي ابدى
النواب السنه رغبه في التمديد له مخرج
الاهم والذي يطفو هو مبدئيا مخرج استدعاء
اللواء ابراهيم من الاحتياط ارتكازا على
قانون تعليق المهن وصولا الى اعتباره
القاضي او القائد الاعلى رتبه وبالتالي
يتسلم مهام الامن العام مجددا ولكن هذه
مبدئيا التخريجه التي يبحث عنها ايضا
مشوبه
بكثير من العيوب والتي يمكن ان تؤدي الى
طلب ابطاله امام الجيش الثوره الدولي وكان
نواب الاعتدال الوطني قد تقدموا باقتراح
قانون هدفه تجنب الفراغ في مراكز امنيه
بغياب اي مؤشرات لحل سياسي يحاول المعنيون
ايجاد صيغه قانونيه غير قابله للطعن
لتفادي فراغ جديد بعد التمديد في معركه
مستمره بين حلفاء على شفير التحول لاعداء
غنوه يتيم العربيه بيروت